[Musique]
le but du jeu construire une ville en
faisant venir des habitants et en les
rendant heureux le jeu de carte happy
city est imaginée par deux japonais
toshiki sato et sa fille héroux repéré
par l'éditeur versailles et cocktail
games api city est aujourd'hui nommé
pour l'as d'or du jeu de l'année dans la
catégorie tout public ce label est
décerné lors du festival international
des jeux de cannes par un jury de neuf
personnes on a de la chance parce que il
ya énormément de jeux qui sont publiés
chaque année avec de la qualité bien sûr
et une création ludique assez
impressionnante c'est vraiment une
reconnaissance du travail bien sûr des
auteurs des éditeurs de la distribuer le
frein de nos distributeurs et la
distribution pour la qualité du jeu même
s'il s'agit de sa neuvième nomination
cocktail games n'a encore jamais
remporté ce prix et espère que cette
année sera la bonne c'est un petit jeu
familial c'est un petit jeu stratégique
et tactique qui est simple d'accès et
simple à prendre en main et à jouer donc
rapide c'est un petit jeu où il faut
construire sa ville donc pour cela on va
construire une ville en dix cartes donc
il faut gérer ses revenus pour avoir
pour acheter des bâtiments et sur ses
bâtiments il y a des des coeurs ou des
habitants parce que le but du jeu c'est
d'avoir la ville la plus heureuse et
pour calculer sur le bonheur d'une ville
c'est les petits coeurs fois les
habitants à la fin de la partie ce qui
fait aussi le succès d' happy city c'est
qu'il existe dans une dizaine de
versions différentes à travers le monde
change ce qui est très simple qui est
facile à apprendre facile à jouer il n'y
a pas de complexité de langage aussi
c'est relativement simple à traduire les
illustrations beaucoup
fonctionnent également
parce qu'ils sont très sympathiques très
très drôle et parfois un peu délirante
api city sera face à carte aventura et
seven wonders architectes le gagnant
sera connu le 24 février lors du
festival international des jeux de
cannes